here with the very latest two of the
most accurate posters in America Chief
pollster at the Trafalgar group Robert
kahaly and The Insider Advantage
chairman Matt Towery you know I won't
mention either your poll in the first
question but Matt what I did see that
was most interesting USA Today Suffolk
poll showing the people that are
breaking late they identified them at
about 16 percent are now now going
overwhelmingly to the GOP do you see the
same thing in the polls you're looking
at
well I think Robert is going to agree
with me with this yes we see late
Breakers going Republican but we saw
three weeks ago and we said this on your
show that we saw a wave developing
across this country moving towards
Republicans anyway so in a sense we sort
of feel like the story USA Today at
least I do is sort of like playing
catch-up to explain why suddenly all the
polls are showing these Republicans
winning we've been showing the
Republicans gaining in Arizona and
Pennsylvania even in New Hampshire which
I think it could be the upset special of
the entire night we've been seeing it
going on for at least three and a half
weeks and it just seems to keep the
building I mean certainly our latest
poll in Georgia Hershey's Herschel
Walker is making incredible uh moves
very late in this race after he's been
beaten to death on television that's a
state where if if you don't get 50 plus
one you'd have a runoff on December the
6th correct
that is correct and and it's still
highly possible that he could be in a
runoff although it will be a little
better this time for any Republican
because they've shortened the time
period of that runoff so you don't drag
on until January that would probably
endure to Walker's benefit in a runoff
all right Robert same question
absolutely I mean that's the one thing
we've been talking about is is when we
measure these undecided and the
undecideds almost every time a breaking
very much antibody so we're not shocked
when these undecideds end up in the
Republican column because you know 60 70
percent of undecided into every race are
anti-viding yeah let me ask you both a
demographic question then we'll go
through the individual races
demographically I'm seeing it in your
poll Rob your polls Robert I'm seeing it
in your polls Matt but in other polls
around the country as well
demographically we are seeing what I
believe to be a pretty big shift in
terms of African-American voters
Hispanic American voters are moving in
big numbers to Republicans I'll give you
two states Georgia and Pennsylvania Matt
Towery
yeah and this is becoming common not
just in those States but Robert and I
both keep getting these crosstabs back
and we consistently see where the
African-American vote about 20 or more
are going for Republican candidates and
when it comes to either Hispanic Latino
or what we call other I mean sometimes
it's 60 something percent for the
Republican I mean not always but these
are things that we've never seen before
I've never consistently seen Republican
candidates getting 20 percent of the
African-American vote this close to the
election I certainly have never seen
Hispanic Latinos or other races trending
Republican like I'm seeing in this
particular year
Robert uh you I know I know I'm looking
at your polls so I see that you're
picking up that Trend as well
very much so and and the two states you
mentioned are particularly interesting
uh with Walker doing 23 uh among black
voters and uh you know the governor Kemp
is doing 20. but what's really
fascinating is how well Oz is doing I
mean we've got oz in the 30s and the
only one in the country that's breaking
20 with African-American women
wow all right now let's go through the
states that we're talking about you
could pick any race that I'm going to
mention here that's fine we have Marco
Rubio in Florida we'll take off the
table I'm not worried about John Kennedy
I'm not worried about Rand Paul I'm not
worried about Tim Scott I'm not worried
about Charles Grassley but we have Rubio
now is up by double digits I guess we
can add him to that list all right but
we have Herschel and Georgia Herschel
Walker against Raphael Warnock then we
have Ted bud in North Carolina then we
have General Don Bolduc in New Hampshire
we have oz in Pennsylvania I think Ron
Johnson is doing better in Wisconsin we
have JD Vance in Ohio we have Eric
Schmidt in Missouri
we have out in Arizona Lake Masters we
have Adam black salt then you've got
these other races we're beginning to pay
a little bit of attention to like
Tiffany Smiley in the state of
Washington Joe O'Day in the state of
Colorado let's go through those States
Robert we'll give you the first crack at
it which ones have you had to pick today
11 days outside the election which
states would you predict go read on
Election Day
I think you end up with Oz uh Walker and
I believe that a masters gets over the
hump I think Smiley's in a dog fight and
quite possible I would actually give an
edge now to bolduck winning and I don't
think O'Day gets gets close enough
and obviously JD Vance you don't worry
about him you don't worry about Ron
Johnson in Wisconsin right right Matt
your take
okay well and the incumbents we just
talked about they're all safe
um let's talk about uh some of these
other races Herschel Walker either gets
in a runoff or win straight up Arizona
Masters was four points down in our poll
uh two weeks ago for the fox affiliate
in Phoenix now it's two points and lake
is rising so quickly and so strongly as
the Republican gubernatorial candidate I
think that could be a sweep and Masters
could win let's talk about uh some of
the others Nevada is laxalt clearly is
going to win that seat Pennsylvania I
think the bottom is falling out of
fetterman's campaign after that debate
and that you saw a huge move when we had
our poll in Pennsylvania for the fox
affiliate there in Philadelphia here's
the issue though so many people have
already early voted in Philadelphia and
did not see the debate which by the way
our polls showed that Oz won it 54 to 21
upon among those who saw the debate I
don't know it's going to be a photo
finish in in Pennsylvania partially
because so many people had voted before
they saw this debate I think the same
day vote and the rest of the vote is
going to be extremely weighted in the
direction of Oz after that performance
by fetterman let me ask both of you this
we see that Joe Biden is hiding out in
Delaware while Jill Biden and Barack
Obama are being brought in as surrogates
in a lot of the states we're talking
about do you see any impact that they
can have on these races Matt
no
none just okay simple answer Robert any
impact
well considering that Joe would be a
negative one I will just say zero
so Barack Obama will be of no help to
democratic candidates
he could potentially Sean in places like
Atlanta with Fulton County which I'm
very familiar with he might increase the
interest and the turnout a little bit
but look the African-American turnout in
Georgia is ticked down in early voting
it started out at 36 percent which is
very robust to win Georgia there has to
be an African-American turnout of at
least 33 percent and as of today in
early voting it's now down to 30 percent
so Barack Obama has got a lot of work to
do if he's going to pull either one of
these candidates through it's not going
to be Stacy if he's going to help
Warnock he's got a lot to do in a short
period of time and I don't see it
working all right last word Robert
not to mention the fact that there's so
many of these uh African-American voters
are going to vote for Walker and gonna
vote for kemp so you got to be careful
who you turn out uh because when they
haven't broken into 80 yet so we're only
70 percent of the people are actually
voting for them turning them out might
not be the Panacea they think it is I
don't think anybody can help Stacey
Abrams at this point I think uh she has
run the worst campaign of of any one
single candidate this cycle all right
Robert thank you Matt Towery thank you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else